just you and me got promote you properly
yes come on if it's reaction take you
reviews three of us reactions usually
just us two okay high reject nation I'm
Greg Alba I'm Courtney right Courtney
right the first guest of the year yes
yeah how are you Courtney okay let's
pretend catch up on camera didn't catch
up before talking great and I've had a
wonderful new year you know always
starting the new year with games that's
the way to go are we transitioning games
like board games oh I play I discovered
a new game called the chameleon you're
letting me down oh we have to transition
to loot game already
I'm so ready first rule of improv you
yes and all right good I'm glad we're on
the same page so if you guys aren't
familiar with loot gaming they are a
part of loot crate but it's like the
gaming version of Cray if Courtney
placed some video games I am still on
Red Dead Redemption - it's gonna take me
at least a year to beat that game have
you played any of it no but I've been
hearing about it it's the forever game
it's the game with one main storyline
and a billion other storylines you can
explore so it takes a long time anyway
Courtney likes to unbox and maybe if
she's lucky I'll give her one of these
things okay
yeah it's Batman
get out yeah I love it you know Wonder
Woman
that is really cool all right here we go
so Courtney since you are the guest I'm
gonna have you pull that stuff for me to
check out so you just feel around
without looking go off feeling and then
we go from there
should I tell you like well okay it
feels like or anything I just pull it
out yeah or you could do a combination
of both
I feel like you set me up for a joke
that I'm not gonna go through okay
are you starting off big are you
starting off with it I am with a t-shirt
what's this shirt that looks like it it
is Haley SPARC Spartan for program oh
that's cool yeah it isn't I'm gonna look
so good in this shirt it's a large you
won't fit in you yes you were extra
extra small
I always tell any woman okay where we
got what we got yeah that sound is great
for the microphone whoa oh it's the
Gallagher bag did you play the circuit
girl yeah I didn't play much of this Rek
but it was like is it a toad yes
everything so I could like go to rouse
and not pay ten cents for a bag you
could cuz that's how it works out is
stylish with your yeah oh yeah oh this
would draw the crowds Corden look you
know so right all of the cashiers would
be so jealous oh my gosh and that is
usually my goal when I go to rouse they
ask for cash back I say what's the max
no give me at all okay we checked my bag
no sir no no I would not have my bag oh
right here I could afford to have on a
dollar cash back but I cannot afford
their tents and Ralph's right that's
cool that's a cute bag yeah I like it
we'll see if you can have it we'll see
what's nice what's next on the agenda
oh okay what's the poster what we got
well we got Mass Effect oh I know
someone who's gonna love that poster you
know it's cool about these is that I can
usually give them away if I need to woo
that is really cool I like it
it's pretty do you want it how what is
that what is this a Gears of War blanket
it's very soft oh wow
oh that is so soft right that is so soft
I'm really not having it up at all
ridiculously soft baby soft
can I just glued together or can I put
this on me oh I got ya oh it's even
clearer on this side game of the year
right here that is like nice and comfy
you get the tote bag I'm pretty sure I
mean this is pretty nice ooh how giving
am i right now
do you play God of War Gears of War and
God of War similar titles alright it
happens I don't know man that's a really
comfy blanket cats will destroy we'll
think about talk about it we'll talk
about you know tune in next week where
Greg and Courtney decide the blanket
yeah we'll still be talking about it and
I'll still be trying to preserve you
know Walking Dead this much more stuff
there's a Galaga pin right here acting
like it's the last one we definitely
need a calendar $60 gift card
yep and how much is little gamey Oh
satirize this is like just for me
everyone gets this one damn that's a
cool deal $60 gift card Mass Effect
calendar awesome my 20:18 cat calendar
as I don't have a 2019 calendar well it
looks like I'm doing like action here oh
[ __ ] this kind of calendar so guys if
you want to get your own loot gaming box
save 10% off on your subscription you
can go to the special link in the
description box use ours loot crate calm
slash eight one eight the real rejects
not the three two three they are liars
and they're not real real you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click I'm
out rowing sorry I don't mean to if you
were a man I wouldn't have yelled at you
[Laughter]
check out Courtney on Instagram and
Twitter Courtney Scott write on
Instagram Courtney s write on Twitter
and Facebook don't offend requester